I've been looking at my facebook feed
and Twitter stream with with great
attention over the last couple of days
and there has been this interesting
trend of people saying hey you know what
we're gonna have to work together we
didn't want a president Trump but we're
going to have to work through our
differences and find common ground and
it feels so disingenuous and ridiculous
because we do have two Americas in the
United States of America there's no way
about it I've been talking about it for
a long time we have one America and I'll
describe both of them to you and it
might resonate with you or it might make
you really angry and want to insult me
because of my Judaism or origin of being
born in Argentina which is part of what
tells us that we have these two Americas
that something that would only strike
some in this country as a reasonable way
to attack what I'm going to tell you we
have one America were secularism science
learning and cultural sensitivity
openness to diversity of ideas and
diversity of people has led to some of
our greatest advancements on the backs
of not exclusively but predominantly
liberal ideas that would have been
stifled if we had let conservatism rain
the 40-hour workweek weekend civil
rights act women's voting rights
national parks the GI Bill the FDA
Social Security NASA public universities
the Clean Air Act the Clean Water Act
the Hoover Dam title nine one currency
for the entire country as opposed to a
patchwork of currencies the right to due
process these are all things that in
some way shape or form were either
partially or completely opposed by what
we can sit what we would consider the
extreme sort of anti-government right
and then on the other hand you have
another America which prides itself on
being anti-intellectual on living in
this alternate reality where whoever is
the current other is bad and to be
feared and gone after and removed and
neutralized however possible uh these
fantasy world ideas about how economies
and societies can be run that have no
correlation to reality
whatsoever and of course often with no
sense that mixing religion and
government and usually it's one religion
and government is bad work together find
middle ground respect each other's ideas
I'd love it if it were possible but how
is it because we have one country that
has advanced so quickly since the
pilgrims made landfall and another
country in the United States of America
that is constantly trying to keep things
as if we were still in the 1620s at
Plymouth Rock so when I tell you now how
progressives should work with Donald
Trump this is not some pie-in-the-sky
kumbaya that we're all going to get
together and have harmony this is just a
few ways in which progressives can maybe
take advantage of some of the ideas that
Donald Trump has gotten agreement on
from Republicans that usually
Republicans would be very much repelled
by so for example it would be best for
progressives not to antagonize the
low-information clowns that supported
Donald Trump which I'm doing right now
by describing them as clowns and and try
to avoid what we would call sort of
identity politics let's criticize
specific individuals for the things they
say and their horrible ideas I'm going
to make the effort Pat although it's
gonna be really tough not to slam the
entire group of deplorable that voted
for Donald Trump I'm gonna work up to
that hopefully by the time Trump is
inaugurated I'm clearly having some
trouble today but from a pragmatic
perspective it would be best to at least
pretend like maybe we could work with
some of these people well even among our
elected representatives there's no
incentive anymore to compromise if you
make a deal with the other party the
donor class is gonna fund your primary
challenger the next campaign yeah and
the days of uh working together Ronald
Reagan and Tip O'Neill working together
to get effective policy past those are
long over yeah and now what we're going
to need to do is basically cherry-pick
as progressives areas where Trump has
bamboozled his base into supporting
ideas that Republicans generally don't
like so number one the left should join
the clueless Trump supporters even
though they barely understand what the
hell is going on in favoring Trump in
terms of less intervention with Middle
East dictators right that was an area
where Donald Trump and Bernie Sanders
were very very similar progressives and
low in from
Trump supporters who think that this is
a right-wing idea should work together
in trying to push from to make changes
to trade agreements to the extent that
it's possible right in a lot of what
trumpet said he's going to do he just
won't be able to do to try to help the
American people stop the trillions of
dollars of waste in the defense and
military industrial complexes even if
the Trump supporters like it only
because Trump said it because when
Democrats say it they don't like it it's
still useful to try to get them on board
to pressure Trump to actually do that
stuff the entire respect for the office
is just not going to happen look at what
Republicans did for eight years of Obama
is as I posted to twitter and facebook
earlier today i am committing today to
give Donald Trump the same support
respect and and admiration of the office
that Republicans gave to President Obama
for the last eight years because
anything less Pat would be uncivilized
unfortunately it's a pretty damn low bar
to set right i mean his successes are
the country successes so in terms of
economic policy foreign policy we hope
he does well yeah on other things like
social issues honestly i hope he fails
this isn't about they did it we will do
it it's about we will respect what there
is that is worthy of respect and there's
a few ideas in there that that could be
good things for all but beyond that
we've got two countries here ladies and
gentlemen and the idea that we're just
all going to come together now is
absolutely ridiculous